at 23 24 25 I didn't feel self-confident
I felt watched I felt like I had to be
everything for everybody all the time I
was called sexy before I ever knew what
SE being sexy was like I was 17 years
old on the on the cover of Maxim and I
had no idea why I was on the cover of
Maxim I was I was honored and I loved it
but I was like what you I remember doing
um Heartbreakers at 23 and the director
was like we just need to be sexier and I
had to pull him aside and I was like I
don't know I don't know what that means
I'm only 23 I know that I'm supposed to
be this thing for people but I don't
know what that means and he had to like
help me figure that out you know and so
it's weird for me when people are like
that's the girl that we wanted you to be
and I'm like that girl was so insecure
and had so confused and like trying her
best but this girl who may not look the
way I like who I am I feel good I'm fine